welcome to this video playing donkey
this is Malaysia yep malaysia um the c3
is Australian you are not not a welcome
sight I was thinking let's play an ID
over something and then c 3 is played
okay yeah i really i noticed recently
that this moves list has come into
fashion bishop to have five not quite
sure why exactly but it has come into
fashion oh yeah well they're very often
white tries this kind of direct
technical thing hmm yeah i really don't
know the opening if i go Bishop d7
probably creepy 3m and this transposes
to Bishop g4 i guess we're going knight
c6 maybe Bishop c4 is played when can i
light bd7 maybe I don't know it's um ok
so it seems to be some sort of no move
yet plated instantly mmm okay i guess i
take it mmm ok i go quincy 7i might be
in some sort of tempo with night the
night coming to be five yeah this looks
very comparable to the Bishop g4 line
but i don't like it very much i'm behind
the development which i never really
appreciate can I may just develop 86
getting the bishop out yeah
I want to get something about this
quickly I take with the Queen at least
the temple right so Queen will probably
go to be three check what really that's
the big idea giving me the bishop pair
for nothing I this must be okay for
black I don't really think that this
should be a b-grade the night to a five
if idea this is an idea this is a really
an idea the night comes here how do I
defend the wall rook c8 c7 that's not a
red and white has a very decent
development that sets clear maybe go
here so that after night a5 I can maybe
play b6
yeah what am i doing now I mean it's
what I'm wondering about is can i play
'if I've it's a very ambitious move but
maybe it's good just if five yeah I like
it it covers deform which is very useful
but it's a bit ambitious as some okay
I'm always playing a very is playing
very let's say slowly h3 is not doing
much I think I thought more like castles
and rookie one trying to do something
against my king in the center okay do I
play be six or do I have anything better
yeah I can't be 6am the next possible
plan could be Bishop e6 a5 a4 yeah let's
do that King f7 rook da doll so possible
okay this is something to be aware of
i'm sort of in a pin here this was
rookie one route g8 i mean the the b6
pawn is weak maybe I should play beehive
even I can do that I can play be five
and maybe em then just retreat the night
somewhere cannot really attack me here
a4 and c4s both them prevent it at the
moment
so if I don't write 2 p-8 yeah I don't
believe know maybe here not be ages I
cannot really that's okay that's okay
controlling c6 you can go nite be 72
c-5m I'll go here need a meal it's
attacked so I need to move it and why
probably needs to attend here exactly to
the spawn or the threat against the pawn
I could play maybe I should do that time
Barney the keep it simple approach just
attack this and intending to spoil this
pawn structure with Bishop f3 so if he
goes 95 what okay
I'm completely baffled now it takes if I
have what kind of group was that okay
yeah well so let's play the Zen gaming
piece up is always nice by taking the
queenside quickly so if the Queen side
is totally frozen now cannot move it and
now i'm going for me for and activate
and the King night and Bishop are
completely shielding here now h5 keep it
blocked check yeah all i needs to needs
to return now yeah or now check yeah
what we'll get zoosk vomit here h 4head
be too cannot defend both
yeah it's a storm at off being quickly
it's not great check yeah I need to get
into pre-move mode badly too
seven seconds that's not really much
checkmate yeah I really needed to switch
gears at the end could have been tricky
very very low on time and some still
completely baffled by this dis capture
on e5 it's just yeah this must be some
sort of hallucination not quite sure
what he was um I was getting at maybe
i'm also not spotting is something here
i mean what i wanted to do is here and
just go back down yeah i thought he
needed to go here and then my idea was
to just get into this end game this end
game where white has this destroyed pawn
structure and also have again this idea
to use the night his pawns are a bit
hampered by by my b 5 a 6 m construction
this should be a quite quite
substantially better for black but of
course it's Jesus just pees very very
hard to figure out what the idea was um
what I do believe though in this opening
I'm really don't every don't know it I
just know that this Bishop f5 is so over
move at the moment i'm pretty sure that
white here really shouldn't play Bishop
b5 and then taoiseach this check gives
black a good game very easily you have
the the two bishops great long-term and
it's not like I'm so far behind in
development i'm a bit behind in
development but without queens on the
board I don't really think that is that
is so so terrible and here maybe well h3
just just loses time I'm not playing
move like Bishop g4 anyway um so I'm not
sure what age three is doing is just
castles and and and rookie one or
something after this after I got time
here to consolidate my position it's
already a very substantial advantage as
two bishops without any compensation is
so a big big edge also my king is far
more active can easily get more active
store and just pieces here the defrost
square is very important that I'm that
I'm controlling that so it's tricky for
him here my general idea is to secure
the spawn and then start with trading
rooks like not be 8 or 9 f8 and just
like we had in the game not quite sure
what the best defenses maybe still not a
file but but here yeah maybe maybe
return but that's very one-sided simply
it's two bishops and the king is active
though so those two things combined is
really am this really a lot alright
thanks for watching